china has long been shooting for the
moon and these tiny lunar rocks it
brought back are one of the reasons why
the moon is is sort of a stepping stone
for a lot of the bigger ambitious plans
that they have far off in the future
these grains of lunar soil provide a
glimpse into the valuable resources
china wants to extract to use on earth
one day
high on its list is helium-3 a rare
substance the moon has a lot of
but even if there is that much helium-3
available on the moon scientists have
yet to figure out how to unlock its
potential but if one nation or one
company one group could figure out how
to do it that would be a game changer
china isn't alone nasa has also studied
the possibility of using helium-3 to
power the earth and companies are
working on grabbing a piece of the moon
too
so to get ahead china is developing
heavy lift rockets and planning a lunar
research base to get closer to one day
mining the moon for rocks like this
at the end of 2020 china successfully
brought back nearly four pounds of lunar
samples and later confirmed they
contained traces of water it's not the
first to make this discovery nasa did
this 12 years ago but from a distance
with spacecraft orbiting the moon
china on the other hand went on the
ground using a probe to analyze moon
rocks in their undisturbed environment
it's the first time this type of
measurement was made on the moon
joseph machelsky is with the laboratory
for space research at the university of
hong kong and he's been studying some of
the lunar samples that were shared by
the chinese government
he says china's ability to do on-site
experiments is one of the first steps in
moon mining it validates the connection
between what's measured on the ground
versus in orbit and that opens up the
door to land there and feel more
confident
this confidence could help china locate
a rare substance as it tries to lessen
its dependence on coal and reach net
zero emissions by 2060. the search for
helium 3 comes at a time in which china
is
looking to diversify its energy mix and
transition towards a cleaner energy
landscape china's lunar exploration team
said the moon has more than 1 million
tons of helium-3 in the soil
scientists say it has the potential to
generate safer nuclear energy in a
fusion reactor that isn't radioactive
and can be used to power the earth
but china's research on helium-3 is
still at a very early stage scientists
still haven't figured out how to map the
lunar surface extract the substance then
process it
so this would require more complex
missions involving not only robotic
probes but also humans on the moon just
the amount of infrastructure that humans
need to survive is more than what robots
need so you need heavy lift rocket to
get more of that stuff to the moon like
you need a lot of thrust to lift large
payloads and also to move quickly so
that you can get humans from here to the
moon
in days not weeks
china hasn't launched one yet but the
country's largest state-owned space firm
said in october that it successfully
test-fired a solid-fueled motor the
china academy of launch vehicle
technology said one day china's heavy
lift rockets would be capable of
carrying a payload of 150 tons to low
earth orbit and if all goes as planned
this is what china says its research
base on the moon could look like
we are here for the long term
exploration
this is china's animation of the
international lunar research station
it's planning to build it with russia
and have it operational by 2035.
on the blueprint the base would be
equipped with communication
energy
and exploration facilities to help mine
the moon
what is likely to happen is to build an
initial module
and then do it sort of ikea style in
other words you have a small one base
and you have a bigger one
then you have a village and then you
have a city
and you carry on
but there are a lot of
unpredictabilities ahead
amid moscow's war in ukraine projects
between the russian space agency and
western partners have been suspended and
that could affect russian research and
its work with china
it's very hard to say
how or when they can achieve this but
when it comes to helium-3 there's so
many points that must be aligned in
order for it to be a reality plus the
industry of moon mining is becoming
crowded nasa is working with commercial
companies to collect lunar samples as
well as startups in europe
but there's one thing that may put
china's mission ahead in this race the
full support of the government they
don't really have the change of hands in
government as frequently there's not so
much political pressure on budget cuts
on this they're able to really look at
things in a very long-term way which is
very advantageous because exploring
spaces is long-term limitless endeavor